well not only bombs are creating more
tragedies for Palestinians but now we're
looking at a new plight cold WT and
possibly floody weather is making the
misery of the Palestinian people more
visible here at this desolation uh water
stations in Rafa City where hundreds of
Palestinians since early hours of the
morning literally we're looking at
hundreds of people gather every day in a
new uh in a new normal defin by
displacement and Terror where people
queue for more than half a day to get a
gallon of drinking water and this
particular day given the weather and the
difficult it's creating on the ground
this plant operates on solar panel and
with with the Sun out of the out of the
side it's making it very difficult to
operate efficiently as there is a need
of at least five solid hours of ongoing
sunlight to keep these desolation
station operating
efficiently we evacuated from Bia we set
up tents in this area the water I'm
getting is for 200 people every day we
cue 4 to 6 hours today we arrived here
early hours of this morning but I'm not
sure if we'll be able to get any water
at this station because it's operated by
solar power and today it happens to be
raining there isn't enough electricity
to operate these
purifiers getting clean and drinking
water is that challenge by itself for
hundreds of thousand of Palestinians the
current situations are making it
difficult for them as they were forcibly
displaced by the ongoing War further
living conditions are hard to avoid with
so many largely unprepared for the cold
weather without suitable clothing
heating or blankets concerns over
survival are high hanim Mahmud Al jazer
RAF evacuation Zone